and now what I'm trying to do I'm
solving putz you right I want to get an
expression it doesn't have any more
integrals in it okay
so therefore I said I what's it equal to
well this is my recurrence relations so
I start to write it but then I don't
write the next bit because it's an
integral right I don't want to need to
lose in this expression so therefore I
say that's okay because I know what I
have n minus 1 is it this right so then
I begin to write this I shall put the
minus sign in and then I'm about to
write this part but I don't want to
write it because it's an integral so I
say that's okay I know what that looks
like - so I write the next part - isn't
it yeah you see what I've done key now
there's my pattern and then I say well
this is just gonna keep going this is
gonna keep on multiplying dot dot dot at
some point he'll get to here right so
then I say okay well I can I can
actually finish this ladder and then get
off this thing right so this is minus -
forever - like that yeah
times minus 3 over 2 times minus 2 over
2
yep and then the last term is x minus ik
one let me stop and make sure that I'm
on the right page
excellent okay now what on earth do I do
with this thing
well the good news is I've kind of
gotten what I wanted right look it's a
statement for my event and there are no
integrals look ma no way two rooms I got
them all of them right I did at end
times I mean I took a bit of a shortcut
in there but we have the patent
assumption that's all I marked okay now
I'm gonna do one thing before I actually
close this up into a nice tight bundle
before I can actually finish yourself
have a look how do we get from one term
to the next in this product
well for starters every single term has
a common factor to notice that there's a
minus one on the new rail and there's a
two on the denominator so there's a
factor of negative 1/2 every single time
if you just take that guy out because it
happens every time
what's left n n minus 1 and minus 2 okay
so this is an AP isn't it but I will
point out it's not the AP that we'll be
doing because we would usually think
about a series which is this Plus this
Plus this Plus this that's an animated
series we're dealing with our product
here so there's that to one side so you
got anybody notice to now the back
continues here almost look you're 4 then
3 then 2 and then you're like oh what
should be here what's missing at that
spot right there there's something
missing what's the next term you would
expect if I didn't show you this last
thing you'd expect minus 1 over 2 now
because it's not there what I want it to
be there so that it finishes off it ties
my entire bunch of terms in a nice neat
bow I'm going to generate this and pull
it out of there okay I'm just gonna do
it so he watch ok so I'm going to write
this this is just gonna stay the same
- outside terms Oh miss times this
doctor talk okay where am I gonna end up
okay well I've got minus 4 2 minus 3
over 2 minus 2 over 2 and then I want
this guy I want that guy so - if Thomas
like completely squared except not at
all right I've got this left over so to
make sure that this this bunch of terms
actually come up to where it came from I
need to multiply finally by 1/2 one
lonely a huff and we should expect that
he's a bit of a reader right because he
came from somewhere else but he came
from actually evaluating a real integral
ok so even though he doesn't fit in the
pattern it's kind of not meant to fit
the pattern because we got him somewhere
else ok now we're ready to really tie
this whole thing up
remember I told you that every single
one of these terms has a common factor
of negative a heart yes negative 1/2
well how many of those negative halves
are there and the answer is if I start
counting from here there's the first one
there's 1 2 3 4 . + minus 1 and minus 2
sorry and minus 1 there are n terms in
this I keep on wanting to say sequence
or series but it's neither those there
are n terms in this product okay so
therefore there are n lots of negative
1/2
yeah now there's the first thing then
you told me if I if I take those guys
out all you're left with is n times n
minus 1 times n minus 2 times all the
way down 2 times 3 times 2 times 1 we
have a name for this right this is in
fact I babe right so because of this
product this is what appears to be okay
now that means these two things together
they take care of all of those terms
right all the parts from the recurrence
relation and then you've got this lonely
guy right
now because he doesn't have a negative
sign on him you don't want to confuse
here with here so I'm just gonna write
that okay
whoa look at that look we just folded
this enormous insoluble thing down into
okay so we got the recurrence relation
then we got out of the recurrence
relation this is not a recurrence
relation anymore okay because it's not a
recursive doesn't depend on any by any
type of I and by this one you know let's
do whatever it's just in terms of em
that's amazing right so the last
question I'm even gonna fit here because
it's got so many to it right the last
question is are this not to one of x
times that in there it's log X to the
five that's what they gave you okay so
what is this in terms of I which pie is
this inside by so so then you say oh
okay who this is according to this it's
1/2 times minus 1/2 now have you this
because of how far we've gone you don't
even need to calculate for this one
there's five there's N and then it's
five factorial okay this is gonna be all
right how many negative ones are there
there are an odd number of them right so
that'll be negative in the years then
you've got 2 times 2 to the 5 which is
64 5 factorial of course you should all
burn is 120 it's under 20 and it looks
to be like there's a factor of 8 that
you could take out of all of this right
is that not obvious well to be honest I
first saw a factor 4 and then I might
I'll still have to even numbers yeah so
if you divide this by 8 I believe you
should get minus 50 they give you think
you'd buy this buy a
okay okay let's see
so the short answer is now that you see
this yes good because because recurrence
relations are built on this n n minus 1
n minus 2 business yeah
so that's that's what the factorial is
defined as so therefore sir oh I see
yeah and you guys you didn't need me to
tell you by the time I've written this
and then written it again you like ah
cool we have you know don't you love the
mathematicians call with excuse me
notation to pull something like that
don't it something like this if if
there's an advice to in verse 4 etc yeah
then you've got a bit boring problem and
then I mean is not there's a lot of nice
leeway to do that and you could involve
a couple of factorials but I probably
wouldn't I probably write it as you know
what it's not the best if I write as M
is 2 times n but is 4 times and by the 6
to the top of the doc what are the last
term is right it might not be even - it
could be 3 it can be anything you fact
only refer to that missing ok now I just
gonna show you this before you get
yourself I suppose but ah here we go
what are the tricky things we make
questions yourself is like sir how did I
go how did I go so this is um this is
what for some fun you should spend a lot
of time all over my father saw amazing a
couple evil from effort didn't exist in
when I was real so what what we
integrated here was a last II I believe
it was X sorry X times I actually had
let's be a bit cheap here I actually had
log X right log X and I had that whole
thing was to the power of five is that
right
and conveniently I didn't even say this
but conveniently boundaries are were
from doctor one okay now when you say
hey what do you think what do you think
he twiddle his thumbs for in a while and
then he's like
yeah - one point eight seven five do you
want to tell me what - 15 over 8 is it's
minus 1 and 7/8 BAM
ok